today's guest is mithuna from looking
glass universe
a youtube channel you should subscribe
to which provides explications into
obscure physics and math topics
such as the schrodinger equation and
bohmian mechanics
mithuna is a bright and promising
individual who recently completed her
phd in quantum computing
in cambridge and we cover her thesis
titled the power of restricted quantum
computational models
we also touch on quantum foundations and
self-studying since this channel is
geared toward the deciphering of
variegated theories of everything
for example there's cast drops there's
e8 there's geometric unity there's m
theory there's chris langans
cmtu loop qg so10
etc and math and physics is the language
of the universe or at least some
part of the universe and powerfully so
this means comprehension of math and
physics is beneficial
though to be fair there is the counter
claim by the mystic types that the
logical mind when
over-developed impedes the intuitive
empirical one and that it's this latter
one that's necessary to perceive the
larger truer picture of reality
either way self-studying seems
indispensable
so there will be more interviews on this
topic for example
tomorrow i'm speaking with fields
medalist richard borchards on
self-learning
self-learning mathematics in particular
quantum field theory's connection to the
monster group
and general problem solving
apologies for any tiredness on display
during this podcast as it was
it was the end of a towering day of
studying and fasting
if you'd like to see more conversations
like this
especially those that explore math
physics
philosophy and consciousness at a
relatively high technical level
then please consider supporting at
patreon.com
slash kurt jymungalas right now
preparing and studying for each of these
interviews takes
the vast majority of my time besides the
time that i spend with my wife
and each dollar each patron is not only
a financial boon
but a large motivational gift of
encouragement
thank you and i hope you enjoy
thank you welcome mythana i appreciate
it thank you for appreciating me
congratulations on your doctorate by the
way thank you
uh yeah like i have technically just
finished up but i finished writing about
a year ago
so it's good to finally be done with the
paperwork
you run a channel called looking glass
universe what are some of the aspects of
that that you enjoy the most and what
are some of the
more detrimental aspects a good question
um so i really enjoy um
teaching something that i think i know
on
on youtube because it generally shows me
that i don't know it anywhere
near as well as i think i do and i need
to end up
learning a whole lot more for for those
videos and often i feel like i learned
more in the process of doing those
videos than like i would even
when i'm researching them for my phd can
you give an example like what was
something that you thought you had
understood and then as you were
explaining it you realized okay there
are holes here
oh my gosh so many things um but like
just just as a whole like
uh something that i like the reason i
started this channel is because i
had done some undergrad classes in
quantum mechanics um
yeah and like done well in them and i
just was like oh well you know i
understand this topic
and people like to learn about quantum
mechanics so i may as well make some
videos
explaining what i know so that's what i
thought this channel would be about
but as soon as i started writing those
videos
i realized like oh i don't know what a
superposition is like
i don't actually know you know
philosophically what this wave function
thing is
um and i realized just basically
everything i thought i knew
i had no idea about and um so i ended up
doing a bunch of research on myself
by myself like i took uh six months off
it was just like reading quantum
mechanics books and then i realized like
there's so much more to this than i
thought from undergrad
and that's what like led me to the phd
kind of like solve some of those
problems
you took six months off just to do
research
um yeah basically just for my own like
offers and i was doing part-time work
to pay for that um but i uh yeah like
basically those six months were devoted
to
um just researching things on my own a
little bit more
so uh yeah like and also making
youtube videos at the same time about
what i've been learning you know part of
when i run this channel i'm curious if
you feel the same
i wonder how is it that people
understand the concepts that they
do without having to explain it to
someone else because part of the
understanding comes from
trying to apprehend it from another
point of view and explain it simply or
explain it from
from some other position and i'm and
there's an advantage to having a youtube
channel
so some people think like you're just
wasting your time because it takes quite
a bit of time to
between the understanding and then
actually putting out a video
but at the same time i wonder how is it
that other people understand what they
do
you know teaching has sort of been
recognized as a very good way to
build understanding yourself for a long
time but um
you the youtube medium i feel is really
special because
you have to try and explain it in a way
that um
someone who may not have the background
can understand as well
and that means you have to rely on way
less assumptions
um and the assumptions are often where
your misunderstandings or
where your not complete understandings
are what's your process of learning
something new in math or physics like do
you just
go to the wikipedia page first do you go
to the stanford encyclopedia
of philosophy do you read it from the
textbook and then how often do you have
to reread and
yeah oh great questions um it depends a
lot on
the topic if it's something in quantum
mechanics now i'll just um
go to the papers read the papers and
then when i don't understand things then
i'll go to
something like um wikipedia or more
likely will be
uh some like textbooks that i trust and
like if they have a section on it then
i'll trust that that section
so for example if it's something quantum
computing or even sort of related to
quantum information
then i will check whether it's in
nielsen and trung if it's there
like that's the bible i'll just read it
from that um but
otherwise like yeah so sort of uh yeah
i'll
read stuff just and then google the bits
that i don't understand
did you ever feel like math or physics
wasn't for you
oh yeah 100 i i definitely
didn't think i would end up in metal
physics um as math especially but
uh even physics so when i was in
high school i was quite like an artsy
kid
you know i enjoyed um like literature
classes and i really loved
painting and i thought i wanted to be a
graphic designer
and then um i took a physics
class about cosmology at some point and
was just blown away by it
completely fell in love was uh certain
that i was going to be a physicist
but even so i was still really really
bad at math
um so i was doing well at physics at the
same time that i was
basically failing math and like in the
lowest grade for
uh lowest band basically in australia um
for math um and uh
like i i kept at it and i
and i decided to put myself into some
really hard math classes just because i
knew i needed it for physics
but i didn't think of myself as a math
person
at all until university where um yeah in
the first year i was doing math classes
and i was doing fairly okay in them and
you know that was all good but they they
weren't like the hardest math classes
but in the second year um i just like
happened to enroll myself
in like a fairly abstract uh like
mathematical course
and just loved it so much like all the
functional analysis
um it wasn't functional analysis i i did
really love the actual functional
analysis but my step in was um abstract
algebra
so uh yeah and like it was really cool
because like you know i remember one of
the first things we were trying to prove
was like
um you know zero plus zero equals zero
and and like getting back to the basics
and understanding
why things are true is like what i
really loved about physics and it was
the same thing that i could love about
math and that
that was an aspect of math that i hadn't
seen in school and so that's why i
thought i was not a math person
because i thought math was just about
like following some algorithms to like
get to an answer that's not that's not
it at all for those people who are
listening
and are interested in physics how
necessary is mathematics to understand
physics yeah i think that
um more than understanding pieces of
mathematics
it's um it's important to understand the
the philosophy of mathematics of in
terms of
how rigorous you have to be and also how
creative you have to be
um and i think that those are things
that people don't usually associate with
math
and so if someone's out there like
thinking like i'm not a math person
i wonder if um you know that feeling
is from from like a misunderstanding
about math
um and if you enjoy physics especially
if you enjoy physics
i can't really even imagine a person who
enjoys physics without
enjoying like the sort of fundamental
parts of maths as well
because ultimately it's about the same
things like getting to the why so how do
you structure your day
methanol how what time do you go to
sleep because i imagine it's like
10 p.m or 11 p.m right there and what
time do you wake up and how often do you
work and
and do you meditate do you have a
schedule
um yeah i try um
so i don't sleep as regularly as i would
like
but i try and you know sleep at eleven
um last night i slept at two
uh so you know that happens um i do
i do meditate i do find that a good way
to start the day
um and then like i mean
what kind of meditation um sort of
mindfulness meditation
um and then i uh have a planner
where i write out my uh goals for the
day
um you know things i'm excited about um
and then also
schedule the day and yeah that that's my
main process it's not like i schedule
every minute
of every day because i'm nowhere near an
organized person
um but i try and vaguely schedule like
what is the most important thing in the
day
and at least like if i can get that one
thing done then i'll feel good about the
day
um and so yeah that's my that's my like
work day and then
um in the evening i like like to drop
down a few little notes about what i'm
going to make youtube videos about
that sort of thing oh okay so you work
on youtube videos each day
just a little bit yeah so for example
what'd you do today
um well so it's just it's morning today
but i'm actually planning
right now in the morning yeah it's it's
uh 10 a.m i think
um but uh i
am planning to make a video today so i
was going to
after this uh write a script out and
just
try and film the video all in one day
which i've never been able to do before
but i'm gonna see if it's possible today
are you able to give a sneak preview
this will go out in a few days so i'm
not sure when your video
will be released ah it doesn't matter
either way um
it's not it's not a secret idea or
anything um
i just want to make a video about what
research
felt like because i think it's a an
experience that's sort of hard to hard
for other people to
um understand if they haven't
experienced it um and
uh yeah and this is yeah just like a
really strange thing to be doing
like to do math research um it
i i was recently talking to another
person who had done a math phd
and um we
we uh talked about like the
the dread of doing math and i think that
that's something that's
really hard for someone who hasn't done
it to understand like doing math
research
um the feeling of is the thing i'm
trying to prove
even true and will i have any like
hope of being able to prove it in in the
three year period that i have
um like yeah the uncertainty is just
unreal
um so yeah i think i want to make a
video about how that feels
how do you deal with the negative
comments on your youtube videos if you
get any
i don't i don't really get any like
uh i think that's just i've been super
lucky because it's still a very niche
channel
and so you know i um generally just have
really nice people who are coming to
learn something about physics so they're
not the kind of person who would leave a
mean comment
so generally all the comments are really
really lovely do you get emails from
people who
try to give you their interpretation of
quantum mechanics and why
okay so how do you deal with that what
is your mindset do you just categorize
it as spam do you respond do you
actually read it
um the thing is i don't have the um
like time to go through
that sort of thing in detail because
people often will send me
sort of papers that they've read um
sorry papers that they've written
and it's it's just i don't have like the
capacity to to be reading everything
um but i guess like
yeah and so it does suck that like
generally i don't reply
um but it yeah because like
it's it's not that i i'm trying to say
like oh i think that you know
this is all rubbish or whatever it's
more that like i'm definitely not the
right medium to be sending it to
and like i'm just one person and i uh
you know get overwhelmed by the the
amount of emails that i get
on this um and the right median instead
is to like go through the like due
scientific process
of like um you know getting other people
who actually understand this topic
because like i'm not even an expert in a
lot of the things that people are
sending me
um to to like yeah to get people like
that on board
um and then the other thing is that like
the times that i have tried to
engage uh with people via
like email or um uh
like you know i have colds like called
them set up a call and stuff like that
to talk about it
i found that um
some people are quite like
i found it hard to interact with
some of these people like i've had some
really bad experiences
um where people kind of
um
i find it hard to accept when i say that
i think something is not right
and and that that's very difficult to
engage with
um so i try to just avoid it these days
they yell at you or they swear or what
oh no no nothing like that no no people
really nice of course but
but um you know like usually i'm used to
when you're talking about like a
scientific
idea um that that it's a debate where if
you
point out a floor in someone else's
argument they have to properly respond
to that flaw
um whereas instead i find like i've
found
the few times where i've tried this that
the person like
doesn't respond to evidence and that's
like not a way that i'm
used to discussing things i see i see
i see okay so let's get to your research
yeah one of the questions i had is
what's a fat shattering dimension
and and did you point that and
i didn't i didn't politically correct
yes but
sharing director dimensions are
something from
um actually i won't even say that um
there's something from classical
computer science
uh i'm not i can't remember exactly what
context they were originally from
i wanna no i'm not gonna i'm not gonna
say it and get it wrong but anyway
um but but uh they are like quite a
technical definition
um but what they really get at is uh
how um flexible
a group of functions is so by that i
mean
like how well would they fit various
types of data
if if uh if it's just like a a line
right like if we're just talking about
linear functions
they're not very flexible only um like
you know very few
sets of data would would uh fit a
straight line
um and so if you're only allowed
straight lines to fit data
then you'll find that like mostly you
don't do a good job of fitting that data
but on the other hand if you suddenly
allow yourself like any degree
polynomials
um they are much more flexible and so
yeah this fat shattering dimension is
basically trying to
um like characterize different classes
of functions and how flexible they are
ah i see so it assigns them a number as
to how flexible they are
essentially okay now you you were
speaking of abstract algebra before
and from what i understand the polygroup
is
well the clifford group are the
stabilizer circuits are the
normalizers of the polygroup but then
from my understanding
a normalizer is
it's in reference to two sets so there's
a group like a large group g and then a
subset
s and then a normalizer would be
i'm sorry i'm trying to yeah i'm trying
to find a way to say this
so you take from a normalizer g would be
i'm sure you know
but anyway it's almost like commuting in
a sense yeah
okay okay but so what is the larger set
g
with respect to this poly group or is
the poly group the largest at g and
they're
missing some subset because they're two
as far as i know in a
normalizer okay um all right let me
get these definitions straight in my
head as well um
okay so how i think of um the
relationship between the polygroup and
the clifford group
is uh like you yeah one way to put it is
um
in terms of uh commutation as you're
saying
but another way to think of it is in
terms of conjugation
so what that means is um if i have a
a a poly operator so that's like a
certain type of matrix
um and i conjugate it so i multiply it
on the left and the right and the the
one on the right
uh i take the inverse um
then the result is going to be another
poly operator
um and like if we translate if we put
that back into the language of communi
communing
what it means is um okay so like for for
the audience um
the reason why we care about this is
because uh poly operators
are sort of important quantum gates so
like if you're
if you have a quantum circuit they're
made up of gates um polio operators are
important gates and so are clifford
operators um
now if you had a a clifford operator and
then a poly operator
you can switch their order and what that
would do
is it would the the clifford gate would
stay as it is
um would be the same one but the pulley
would become another pulley
and that's important because like the
poly
like operators have really nice
properties that we want to kind of
preserve under conjugation
we can't exactly keep it um the same
under conjugation because it does
uh change when it becomes when it swaps
with a cliffit
but it still stays a poly which is still
nice and so that's like
the reason why this uh this is like a
really important idea in quantum
computing
how does one go about proving that a
particular quantum algorithm
is efficiently simulable classically so
is it something like you reduce it down
to something else that's been proven to
be
simulable classically oh yeah good
question
um so yeah maybe to give a little
context on like why
um i was interested in that question um
you like might have heard that quantum
computing
is you know better than classical
computing
um and that's in the sort of like um
sense of
algorithmic complexity you know there's
some questions that a
quantum computer can solve in polynomial
time that a
classical computer can it seems only
solve in exponential time
um and uh but what i was interested in
is like
which computations can a quantum
computer do better
like why what's like special about that
quantum computation
um and uh
how like one of the main methods i used
in my thesis to like study this question
um was this idea of efficient classical
simulability
so you have some quantum computations
that are efficiently simulable
um what that means is that computation
could have been done on a classical
computation in
a time like in a similar amount of time
right the difference is polynomial
exactly um and so uh the way
to do that is is actually really
straightforward you find the algorithm
so you have this quantum algorithm and
then you want to prove that there exists
a classical algorithm that is like also
like fast um just find the algorithm
find the classical algorithm literally
write out
what you would have to do step by step
to simulate this quantum algorithm
is there much creativity involved in
that what i mean is that
is it a fairly standard set of a fairly
standard procedure
or do you have to think completely
outside the box oh yeah there's
there's this mathematician her name is
lisa
piccarello have you heard of her she
determined that the conway
knot was a slice and it was like this
unknown problem for
20 years and then she just worked on it
as a grad student and the most
the brilliant part of her of of her
proof
was coming up with another knot like
she had to come up with some nod and
then to prove that it has some property
yeah but just come
coming up with that not it's not trivial
it's a strange not why would you come up
with that so i'm wondering is it the
same with
coming up with an algorithm yeah going
back to that point of like what it feels
like to do math research like
that that's that's the thing like you
never know
where like what is going to be the right
idea that's going to prove this fact
right or even if that fact is true um
and so
you know in her case like that she
probably tried all kinds of things and
uh or you know had some great insight
about like why this knot was like very
related
um it was similar with like you know my
research
not anywhere not to compare myself to
anything like as grand as anything like
that
but um like yeah it you don't know where
you're gonna go
and there is no algorithm for um finding
any of these things
like when you're trying to prove
something it is totally like a new thing
and you have to really like get to the
core
of why it's true to be able to prove it
right i know you said you don't want to
compare yourself to doing anything
anywhere near as grand as that but i
think that you
you have a result and again i skimmed
your paper so please if i get it wrong
it seems like you extended the gotzman
nil theorem and that
gotzmanil is already a fairly remarkable
result which means
yours is groundbreaking no it's really
not
um like absolutely true that the got7
canelo
theorem is got a nail there and it's
i don't know how it's pronounced i just
read it yeah me neither
i always go both ways anyway um is
yeah an absolutely remarkable and like
really important
um theorem in quantum computing uh the
way we extended it
um yeah i am very pleased with but um
like
i don't feel like i should take a lot of
credit for that because
basically there was another paper that
did a lot of the technical work
but didn't necessarily recognize that um
that by adding like one extra step on
top it would become an extension of the
goddess mcniel theorem
um and so like we we did that and so the
technical work was not that big
it was more the conceptual work of
realizing these things were linked
i see i see okay so goddess menil so
i've been calling it gotzman nil
okay so goddess manil the theorem it
says something about the clifford group
and that
if you take elements from that and
create a circuit then you're
you'll be able to be efficiently
stimulable as well something like that
now what was your extension to it
yeah sure so the gross manual theorem um
says that uh like a very large class
like a surprisingly large class of
quantum computers are
efficiently classically simulable and at
the time
this was this was huge like this is just
really unexpected
because um the class that you're talking
about is like yeah the clifford group
and the clifford group involved like a
lot of
important quantum computations um or
like
sort of things around quantum
computation
um involve the clifford group uh so for
example error correction
and um quantum teleportation super dense
coding all
entirely clifford um and so like this is
a
an important class of quantum computing
and it also is like quite a large class
because
uh there's this other theorem that if
you take just like one other random gate
like pretty much with certainty
um uh you will end up with like
universal quantum computing so if you
have like clifford gates plus just like
one other random great
you basically get the whole thing and so
cliffords are in a sense like
any random gate with high probability if
you randomly choose a gate with high
probability you will get
um the universal group uh so
like in a sense you're like one step
away from being universal by being
clifford
um and yet like being clifford is
entirely classically simulable um like
you can't do any quantum computations
that are super fast
using the cliffords despite all of their
good properties and despite being like a
really big class
and so that's why the guys veneer
theorem is like really interesting and
something that like i was very
interested in
um because i was interested in like yeah
what's special about quantum computing
it's like
it can't be anything that's inside of
the clifford gate group even though
even though a lot of very exciting
things are there like for example bell
states which are the maximally entangled
states
you can very easily make them with
cliffords and yet
somehow that doesn't contribute to like
um quantum speed up which is weird
um so what i was interested in is like
uh
yeah like okay if you add
uh if you add like another if you
have a circuit that has cliffords in it
and then you allow yourself
um like one other gate from outside of
the
the clifford group um how much power is
that
is it like entirely the whole thing or
or does it matter how many of these you
add like let's say there's a like you've
okay there's this thing called the t
gate which is like the sort of canonical
extra gate that you add to
i had a question about the t-gate
actually that now that you're bringing
up is that
this is that a short name for to folly
or is that like a
phase shift of some kind yeah it's a
phase shift it's um
not the to folly gate uh yeah so they're
totally gay
yeah okay i just want to know because i
read t but i wasn't sure what t meant
from context yeah exactly so okay if i
was just allowed to add one of those in
um is that hard to simulate or if i was
to
add like a polynomial number of those in
like that that definitely is hard to
simulate
um but like what's the in between like
you know
where how does it go from like if you
have zero of them it's completely
classically simulable if you have a
polynomial amount it's universal
like where where like you know how
important
are the is the dependence on t gates and
if if you found
a result like oh adding one extra t gate
makes your thing like
hard to simulate then it would suggest
that the goddess midnight theorem is
just sort of like a weird coincidence
and it's not really that important like
it's not really saying
that like these other other gates are
like super important
it's just a like weird fact that if you
have zero of them that
like you know it doesn't um that it's uh
easy to simulate um so i wanted to know
whether that was the case or
if they're if like the
amount that the difficulty of classical
simulation
scales with the number of tea gates so
as you add more tea gates it gets harder
and harder to classically simulate
um and that's like what you would
suspect if you uh
like if you kind of believe the sort of
moral um like
interpretation of of the goddess manila
theorem
and that's what we basically proved um
that like
you uh oh okay i should i shouldn't say
that
like that had been proved um so you
this oh sorry i'm just going to turn my
camera back on all right
it's a dslr yeah uh
it's recording again okay cool um so no
no i i shouldn't say that
like we proved that um that had been
proved that you can classically simulate
like the the difficulty of classical
simulation scales with the number of tea
gates had been proved
but what we proved was um like related
to that
like if you have uh a certain number of
tea gates in your circuit can you in a
sense like
remove out all of the clifford stuff
which is all the easy bits
and just leave like the hard tea gates
behind um
and and we showed that that was possible
um right so
yeah which one of your papers are you
most proud of there's
as far as i can see there are three at
least referenced in your thesis
i'm gonna read them out loud quantum
advantage of unitary clifford circuits
with magic state
inputs the one clean qubit model without
entanglement is classically simulable
and
a condition under which classical
simulability implies efficient state
learnability so which one of those do
you think
is the most significant 100 think it's
the
the middle one um it's the uh
that um the one clean qubit model
without entanglement is classically
simulable
uh that that was the result basically
that i started a phd to get
um i and and also
the result that i very nearly didn't get
um despite spending years on it
i maybe spent five years on that that
single topic
um so yeah uh why
it was such a big deal is yeah there's
this very interesting hypothesis
in quantum computing that entanglement
is
the main ingredient of a quantum
computer
that somehow it's like the weird
bit of quantum mechanics that like a
quantum computer's taking advantage of
to get all these speed ups is
entanglement
and um like yeah it's a very
sort of dominant uh like ideology in
quantum computing um despite the fact
that like yeah there's
it hasn't been proved either way um and
like the evidence for it is like i would
say fairly weak
um so evidence that evidence that
entanglement does have something to do
or doesn't have something to do
that it does um like i'd say it's i mean
it's not
maybe weak is the wrong term like it's
just like it's not a strong case it's
suggestive but it's not a strong case
um so like my supervisor and uh
um like his co-author a long time ago
have proved
um that if you have no entanglement
inside of your quantum computer
like your um erls quantum computer
then you get something that's
classically simulable which is very
suggestive that that entanglement's
important
right um but there were some reasons why
um this may like
not sort of extend nicely um one is that
that it works when you have zero
entanglement but it doesn't work well
when you have like a a small but not
zero amount of entanglement like what
you would expect
is similar to what i was saying about
the goddess mcniel theorem you would
expect that like
as you increase the entanglement it
becomes harder and harder to
classically simulate that that result
has never been shown
um and in fact probably
i i suspect it can't be shown exactly by
the way when you say it gets harder and
harder to show that it gets
classically simulated why is it not just
it is classically simulable or not why
is it that there's a continuum
yeah okay so um when we say something's
easy to classically simulate we mean
it's polynomial when it's hard it's
exponential
but if the exponential is so like
let's say uh there's some parameter like
the amount of entanglement or the number
of t gates there's some parameter like
that
um where the cost of classically
simulating
this um quantum computer scales with
that term
so it's like e to the power of that term
then
it suggests that like as you add more of
that thing it's getting harder and
hotter i say i see it
yeah okay um yeah so uh
so your one qubit clean model yeah clean
that
okay yeah so um the
entanglement case hadn't been shown well
even for um like what we call pure state
quantum computers and so these are the
sort of idealized quantum computers that
have no noise in them
but um real quantum computers have noise
in them
and you might think okay but that's like
not sort of mathematically relevant like
okay that's relevant for engineers but
who cares about that from the maths
point of view
but actually from math point of view
these like noisy quantum computers are
super super interesting because
they they have like very different
mathematics and like
much more complicated and sort of um
like in a way that the where where like
i'm almost skeptical of results that are
approved only for pure state quantum
computers and not for mixed state
quantum computers
because it it feels like that might just
be a quirk whereas like the real thing
is these noisy things
um and so like no result like that had
been proved for noisy quantum computers
so like the result you would want is
um without any entanglement for a noisy
quantum computer
there is no uh like if if you have no
um entanglement in a noisy corner
computer you have no quantum advantage
that would be the result that like we
would love to show is true or false
um and so i had started this project
kind of trying to come up with a counter
example i wanted to find a noisy quantum
computer
that had no entanglement that still had
a quantum advantage
um and so uh there was like a very good
candidate
there's something called the one clean
cubic model and it's like really
fascinating basically it's a
quantum computer that has one qubit
that is um like clean or pure
um and what that really means is we know
exactly what state it's in
and then you have the rest of the qubits
in that
quantum computer are completely dirty in
other words like we have no idea what
they're doing they could be doing
anything
um and usually if you have like a set of
just like dirty cubits
you can't do anything with them because
like if you don't know anything and you
do something to them then you still
don't know anything right
but adding this like one qubit where you
do know what's happening
like completely changes this model so um
it's like remarkable but like yeah you
have this one qubit you know and all
these computes where you don't know
anything
you do some processing to it and then
you measure something at the end that is
actually genuinely useful
and can like solve some like problems
that
appear to be classically hard to solve
uh so
so that's the one clean qubit model but
the thing that was very interesting
about it and why it made it a good
like candidate for me to study was that
um there's this result that the one
clean qubit and the rest of those noisy
qubits
never become entangled with each other
despite like throughout the whole
computation
which like is very strange because you
like
you know the one cleveland cupid is
clearly somehow the one that's like
giving its quantum power to the rest of
the rest of the cubits who have no power
so you would expect that if there's
communication between those two sets
that it would be via entanglement if
entanglement is important
um and so like the fact that there's no
entanglements like very suggestive that
there's something else going on
and so i wanted to study the one clean
qubit model where there's no
entanglement
not just between those two qubits those
like this the clean cube it's not
volumizing ones
but within the noisy ones there's no
entanglement within them as well
um so like there's no entanglement
across any of the qubits like none of
the qubits were allowed to talk to each
other
that way um and
yeah what i found was that um
like yeah we were studying this topic
for a long time and i was very very
convinced
that this quantum computer with no
entanglement would have
like some quantum advantage because it
was very complicated and
if it's complicated it suggests that
it's hard to classically simulate which
suggests it's doing something that's
like genuinely quantum um
but like yeah after a few years of
working on it
um it suddenly occurred to me that i
could i could classically simulate it
like i
figured out what the algorithm was and
it was a huge process from that point
to like actually writing down the
algorithm for sure but
um but yeah like it uh
it really like surprised me because i
thought i was going to prove the
opposite thing
um right right that we proved this
instead uh actually
makes me quite convinced now that
entanglement is important now do you
need to know something about the
dirtiness of the rest of the qubits or
are they just left as
noisy and you don't care about how noisy
yeah you you actually assume that
they're maximally noisy there's
something called magic
distillation and i was reading uh just a
wikipedia
article about it and it says okay well
here's what you can do you can have an
input you prepare five imperfect states
then your output is
in almost your state having a small
error probability and then you repeat
until the states have been distilled to
the
desired purity okay then i was wondering
is there something about five
because it says prepare five imperfect
states or is that just on wikipedia um
there's not something about five uh
but the reason why they would have said
that i don't remember exactly but i
think
the one of the um state distillation
protocols uh involves
yeah like a five cupid thing um and
interestingly um
state distillation is done by by
cliffords so so this would have been
like
a particular profit property of like a
particular five qubit sort of set of
cube of of um cliffords have you studied
much of quantum logic
um no actually almost not at all
yeah okay well you know either way maybe
you can speculate i wanted to know
because girdle's theorem girdles and
completeness theorem is based in
classical logic
and so i'm curious is there a quantum
logic analog
and what does quantum logic have to say
about girdles in completeness theorem
essentially
do you have any thoughts on that yeah i
do um
so my gut reaction is not much
um and the reason for that is
um there's so there's sort of two
levels of uh computation
that are
relevant here um there's there's the
level of like
decidability um and so this is like what
the halting problem is about and what
goals and completeness theorem is like
you know
in a sense about um and that is like
okay if you have a mathematical
statement
um can you decide whether it's true or
false right
um and like this is sort of like given
an infinite amount of time
and resources um and
then there's like the sort of uh
compu computational complexity point of
view which is like okay the same
question can
can you decide whether this is true or
false but can you do it in a
reasonable like so polynomial amount of
space and time
um and the quantum like so
the the stuff that's proved about like
turing machines and all of that
is um true regardless of quantum
mechanics it's true regardless of like
what your implementation um like
mechanism is
whereas uh the computational complexity
stuff is where like the quantum versus
classical like difference really is
and since um like yeah girdles and
completeness
theorem is like on that that side of
like sort of purely about decidability
i would i would i would suspect
that quantum logic doesn't change that
outcome
does quantum computing have anything to
say about the solution
or solving potentially the halting
problem no
because a quantum computer can be
classically simulated just inefficiently
right like
right computation can be can be
simulated by a classical computer it
would just take a long time
and so if you have a quantum computer
that can solve the halting problem
then you already have a classical
computer that can solve your
so no quantum computers say nothing
about that is there a difference between
quantum computers and a probabilistic
turing machine
um yes so a probabilistic turing machine
is a um okay wait let me just get this
right
yeah um so a probabilistic turing
machine
is um like the class of problems the
class of
decision problems that a um
probabilistic turing machine solve
is uh what we call bqp and there's like
a strong suspicion in the
like computing um community that
uh that this is equal to p and p
is like this class of problems that you
can solve with a touring machine like
just a regular turing machine
um whereas a quantum computer um
is is stronger like we suspect than a
probabilistic
turing machine although there's some
like um
yeah i mean yeah with sensible
definitions it's definitely stronger
um but then the question is like is it
strictly
bigger like is it a strictly bigger
class the the
um class of quantum computations than
than this one
like the classical ones so do you find
that there's any implication for quantum
computing or
or your research in general and the
problem of p equals np
or is there no relation yeah yeah no no
absolutely
um so yeah like
on the question of p equals mp um
the fact that p equals mp hasn't been
proved
has is like
it it's like one of the base assumptions
of quantum complexity of not quantum
rather um computational complexity
and the fact that it hasn't proved been
proved means that like basically nothing
else can be proved
um so like for example our quantum
computer is better than classical
computers
we have lots of evidence to suggest yes
but we can't prove
it because if we could prove it um then
we would already be able to prove that p
doesn't equal mp because
um well at least for decision problems
like if we could find a
so there's like you know in the decision
problem hierarchy there's this p
and then there's like np which we think
is bigger um
but if we could even find one problem
that is definitely in np and not in p
right we would you know but
for quantum computing to be better than
um uh than
um classical computing we we would have
to
like and to be able to prove that we'd
have to find a problem outside of p
that um a quantum computer can solve but
if that problem existed
um it probably is inside of np and so
we've probably already improved p equals
mp
um and so yeah like it is a first step
to proving that quantum computers are
better than classical computers
and a first step to many things in
quantum in computational complexity
which
like yeah all depend on on assuming
that's true
so prime factorization that's an np
correct
um yes but it is not a hundred percent
proved to not be in p that's the problem
i see i see
so in fact no np problems have been
proved to definitely not be in p
okay as far as i know there's a
difference between np problems and then
np
complete problems is that okay so is the
prime factorization np complete or just
np just mp
okay okay okay yeah certainly it's
certainly not complete because we
don't suspect that quantum computers can
solve np complete problems
i don't know if you saw maybe you
already saw the video it's uh
it's richard e richard e borcha's
orchards i might be butchering his name
anyway for the people listening he's
coming on this podcast at some point
he's a feels medalist and he said here's
how my teapot
is better as better quantum computer the
reason is that it can solve a problem
that quantum computers can't
and then he's like well what is the
problem the problem is how many pieces
can this teapot shatter into
well this teapot can solve it better
than a quantum computer is better than
any computer
and then he said well this is a foolish
example and it's contrived on purpose
because
when you hear in the media that quantum
computers are better than classical
computers it just
it's like better on what it depends on
the test so if you design a test that a
quantum computer is
efficient at well you haven't said that
quantum
computers are better as a whole he he
said it's like giving an
intelligence test to an anteater and
showing that it's but it's smarter than
einstein because you say that
the intelligence test is how many ants
can you eat in a minute it's like okay
well you can try the test to show that
this particular
i i think that um there's one very
big flaw in that analogy and that is
that
we can prove that quantum computers can
do everything that a classical computer
would do
um like everything that a classical
computer can do a quantum computer can
do and we can write that
that algorithm like straight off the bat
there's nothing there's nothing like
difficult about that what is up in the
air is like
is there extra things that a quantum
computer can do so i agree with him that
um you know those extra things may not
be interesting things and then
who cares about quantum computing but
but like it's definitely the case that
they are better than classical computers
like that's not the argument
um the argument is like what things can
they do and
well maybe one of the points that he's
making is like one of the main
things that we know a quantum computer
can do well is it can simulate quantum
mechanics
so that's like probably one of the
biggest use cases for quantum computers
in the future
like you know drugs are uh like
like you know molecules are basically
like quantum machines and it's the
quantum mechanics
aspect of them that makes them very hard
to simulate classically
um hopefully you know quantum computers
will be able to do a better job of them
so like sure like we are designing
our tests to be like a thing that
quantum computers can do very well which
is like quantum mechanics
um the question is do we care about like
quantum mechanics
what's the koch inspector theorem and
then what does it have to say about
quantum contextuality
so i usually say questions because i'll
say that on other
sure sure i'm completely getting that
wrong um anyway so
um the questions vectors theorem is a
very um
important theorem in uh
quantum foundations and what it's
addressing is like
um so you might have heard of hidden
variable theorems uh
it's like a way to get around the
weirdness of quantum mechanics
so it says that you know there are no
such thing as
uh no such things as superpositions like
these these particles are not doing like
all possible things at once
um instead they are in one particular
place doing one particular thing but
the way they act is very complicated um
like it can be
uh like determined by a
um you know forces that like take into
account
all the possible things they could be
doing for example like so that's how
birming mechanics works
um and there was like quite a
big push in quantum foundations to like
try and roll these theorems out
um which isn't like totally possible
because like yeah for example bohmian
mechanics exists it exists like whether
you
like it or not um but uh
what like the question spectre theorem
tried to do and what like
um other theorems since have tried to do
is
prove that these hidden variable
theorems have undesirable properties
um and so what the undesirable property
that the questions factor theorem shows
is um something called contextuality
so what that means is uh
if you have a variable like a thing that
the particle is doing that you're
interested in
um let's say the spin of the particle so
uh
spin like you you wanna like in in
quantum mechanics
you would say that the particle is like
a superposition of spin up and spin down
but in uh hidden variable theorem
presumably you'd want to say
this particle is spin up right and
um how would you say that well you'd say
like okay if i measured it now
and it was spin up um then it was spin
up before that
right um but what what the questions
vector theorem shows
is that actually um that isn't a good
way to be thinking about that theorem
because if i had that same particle
and instead of measuring it this way
like with a particular instrument this
way
if i turn that instrument on its head um
and measured
uh and then like did the sort of like in
post
um like figured out like what the spin
should be
what do you mean you turn the
measurement on its head yeah so like
so this sort of canonical way to measure
spin is to get a stone garlic machine
which is like
has a certain type of magnetic field
that kind of points upwards
um and if a particle goes upwards
we would say that spin up but what we
could do instead
is we could turn it on its head now
literally
literally literally turn it on its head
and now a particle that goes
um oh am i going to get this right
yeah so now the same particle if it was
spin up should go down
um and so we would still say that spin
up but like
with but we've measured it differently
right so it's just the measurement
operator
apparatus that is different but like the
sort of results should be the same
but what quotient spec has showed is
that in fact
if you had that particle um that was
that
like you know we're going to measure and
you measure it the normal way it would
go spin up
but if you turn the machine on its head
now you should expect it to go to spin
down but it would in fact
still go spin up um and so that suggests
that this property
is not a real property of that object
it's a property of the way
we measure the object which like is
not nice um the the response to the
quotients of echo theorem though in like
terms of bohmian mechanics
or other hidden variable um things is
well in body mechanics spin is not a
real property
of a particle and in fact no
um like none of the kind of variables
that you can make from the quotient
spectra
theorem are real variables like truly
considered to be properties of the
particle
in both mechanics they're essentially
emergent properties like in bromine
mechanics the real
like properties that matter of the
particle are its position
essentially and then you can derive its
momentum from that um
so position is the only real variable
everything else is just like emergent
and so the fact that like yeah if you
measure it this way it's up and if you
measure it that way it's down like
it doesn't matter to bombing mechanics
because that wasn't a real property that
it cared about about the particle anyway
okay now this rotating of the stern
gerlac apparatus
is that a contrived example or is that
actually in the cochin specter theorem
ah so the question spoken to theorem is
a much more general
theorem than that like um well the
reason i'm asking
sorry the reason i'm asking is because
in that example physics
is invariant under rotations translation
and so on so how does the particle even
know
if you've rotated your apparatus that it
oh because if you rotate the apparatus
you've changed
the direction of the magnetic field like
that's real um like if you rotated the
entire universe then the particle
wouldn't be able to tell
but if you rotate a single part within
it yeah
okay yeah the question spectrum theorem
is like way more general um but this is
like one of the scenarios that it would
apply to
why don't you explain what quantum
decoherence is and why it either solves
or doesn't solve the measurement problem
oh that's such a great question um okay
so uh decoherence is a
like very on the surface mundane
thing about quantum mechanics and it's
just
uh the fact that um as
you uh like as you okay so you have
some particle in a superposition let's
say a superposition of spin up and spin
down
and then something interacts with it
let's say a photon of light
and the photon of light will act
differently if
the particle is spin up or if it's spin
down so that light particle will go into
a different state depending on which of
those two
properties it's in um so now in quantum
mechanics we would say that it's
entangled
with uh with the original particle
because
um its state depends on the state of the
original particle so that's like what
entanglement is
um and so then uh okay like that's
that's all good
but now imagine that that photon just
like leaves
and you never see it again and you'll
never be able to measure it
but you try and measure your original
particle now if an or if your original
particle is in a superposition
normally you'd be able to tell that it's
in a superposition you can do like a
double slit experiment on it something
similar
um to tell that it is in that
superposition
but even though it's still in a
superposition um and like nothing has
changed from the quantum mechanics point
of view because
you have no you haven't got access to
that photon if you do the math
you can like show that this particle now
acts as if it's collapsed to one of
those two states
like you will not be able to tell the
difference between a collapsed particle
and what's really happening which is
it's still in a superposition but
a superposition that involves this
photon that is now inaccessible
um and so that's like yeah it's on the
surface a bit mundane
but um the implications are really
profound because
here is a mechanism by which you can get
measurement collapse without measurement
collapse like so something that
looks and feels to us exactly like
measurement collapse like mathematically
entirely equivalent and yet all that's
happening is normal quantum mechanics
and so you can just get rid of that last
postulate of quantum mechanics entirely
and just replace it with like
just just just delete it and you still
get the same results
sorry when you say you can get rid of
the last postulate of quantum mechanics
you're referring to
oh yes the the measurement postulates so
the collapse postulate
um that so like yeah there's the the
thing that's really nasty about quantum
mechanics and like the
like i think real problem with quantum
mechanics is that there's two
systems there's like what how quantum
quantum objects like act when there
is no measurers around and no devices
around to measure them
they just like evolve unitarily it's
very nice
but then suddenly as soon as you add
something that you call a measurement
device
and like who knows what that is um you
have to have like
different rules of physics that are like
incompatible
like they just don't work together and
like this is just
untenable mathematically and
philosophically like it's just
ugly um whereas the
the whole d coherence thing gives us a
way out what it says is
forget about that second regime
measurements are not real measurements
are a
um a phenomenological thing that comes
from just the regular
um quantum mechanics uh like there is
never measurement
collapse instead um there's only
superpositions
but because some parts of those
superpositions become inaccessible to
you as like you add more particles and
they all become entangled and then those
particles fly off or whatever
you can't measure them your your object
that is still in a superposition now
looks as if it's been measured and
therefore like
that is like measurement but it's not a
real thing it's just a
an emergent property does this have any
implications for the many worlds
interpretation
yes absolutely um so
many worlds uh people often take
this um decoherence as like a
sort of uh important
important ingredient in their theorem um
but they're like many worlds i would say
uh
is basically take quantum mechanics
seriously forget about the measurement
postulate like it doesn't exist
and so then the question for them is
like okay but if you don't have the
measurement postulate
how do you how do you um like explain
what happens in the lab
where it seems like you know measurement
happens and collapse happens
they would just say well it's just
decoherence so we didn't need
measurement all along and i would say
that is the
many worlds interpretation i thought the
many worlds is about the splitting of
the universe because you measure and it
collapses into one but you're saying
that forget about collapsing
it's not yeah it many words i feel like
that's a misinterpretation
um many worlds has nothing to do with
measurement
um it is what it says
is if you have some objects in
superposition
um they continue to be in superposition
they never collapse to just one state
so whereas like the standard
interpretation says like okay let's say
i have a
particle it could be spin up spin down
um
i uh measure it and now
it becomes spin up and i measure spin up
so there's only one world and that's the
world where it would spin up
whereas what many worlds would say is
okay you have this particle
superposition of up and down
you measure it what that really means is
you interact lots of particles like
lots of other particles with it they
decohera
to you it will look as if the particle
is um you know spin up or spin down
but really what's happening is that
there's still a superposition
um and then
a thought experiment about this called
quantum suicide and immortality have you
heard of it
okay so essentially what i'm wondering
is under the many worlds interpretation
do you
not live forever because if we define
you as the experiencing you
because by definition you can't
experience when you're dead
so why is it that you don't live forever
because there's no world where
where you get to live forever right like
okay let's say
um i'm gonna think about myself and all
of the
many superpositions i can go into from
this point
um so there's many things that could
happen to me that that put me in
superposition
uh maybe like something to do that with
weather is a quantum fluctuation i don't
know how that could happen but like
let's just say
you know it might rain tomorrow because
of quantum mechanics or it might not
so there'll be a version of me that
experiences the rain and one that
doesn't
but in both of those worlds i will die
eventually like there's no
immortality there and like in every
sort of possible world um that is like
dependent on a quantum
fluctuation uh like i can't see any of
those worlds where i become a model
is there not a world where your dna is
constantly repaired and the earth
and the sun doesn't burn out and so on
so you do live forever so the laws of
physics have to be obeyed in every one
of these
universes um so the sun will inevitably
burn out
um just there unless like there is
i i mean i can't see it but like unless
there's some
way for it to not happen quantum
mechanically
but i don't think so um so the sun will
burn out in every one of those universes
um my dna repairing is not down to
quantum fluctuations
it's down to other um other factors
which like
couldn't go both ways and so um
like that that's also not a past
immortality and how about this
okay methune is instantly recreated
you're now 18
and it's like perfect health you're
probably already in perfect health but
you're now 18.
and there's a is there not a small small
small chance of that
occurring right now just a poof version
of methune
that breaks the laws of physics somehow
so the way that i'm imagining this is
that there's a continuum of where the
electron can be
and then that is for every single
electron in your body and then
that is also for every single proton in
your body and so on and so so you just
transport yourself
yeah so i think that is a
that this is like no different from um
you know if i like because anything
could uh sort of spontaneously
um come into being right like because
because of like
very freak quantum um uh fluctuations
but like let's say that you know um
you're sitting here and then like on the
other side of the universe
uh the the eiffel tower just like
materializes
on on some other random planet right um
now it's it's a sort of philosophical
question
whether you count that as the eiffel
tower is it the same thing
right um and so like if a version of me
just materializes randomly
somewhere else in the galaxy uh is is
that
is that me um well i wouldn't experience
it being me because i
i only have my continuous experience um
from this body
um so that that person if if
if they materialize with all my memories
of course will think of themselves as me
but i would think of them as
as a person distinct from me um and
there's no sort of
um contradiction there and also it
doesn't grant me
myself any immortality even if uh like
this keeps happening
do you think of yourself as the same
person when you wake up
um because you're gonna get yeah this is
it yeah
um so this is like all you know like
deep philosophical questions have been
debated for a long time
but yes i do think of myself as the same
person when i wake up
and something to do with the continuity
of experience or
something about being able to um like
uh remember even if it's inaccurately
what it was like to be that person
before
um like makes me feel like the same
person
whereas if there's another version of me
even if they have the same memories as
me
and they themselves therefore think that
of themselves as me like they
both of us imagine out like past
smitherena as
their past and that is 100 accurate
i would not would not associate with
that person because that person is not
sharing any experiences with me
i'm curious about the implications if
the universe is discretized
spatially or temporally does that have
any implications for quantum computing
because i imagine that a large part of
the power comes from that there's an
infinite
amount of intermediate states between
zero and one and so if you can
discretize in some
manner then the the bloch sphere
is also discretized or is it not that's
a good question there's different ways
to discretize right there's just
discreteness in time in space and
then what you're talking about which is
discreetness in terms of um what
superpositions are allowed
i can't remember this result of the top
of my head but i have this vague feeling
of reading a
result that was um along the lines of
discretizing
what superpositions are allowed and you
still get like
the the regular power of quantum
computing so i would disagree that
the the power of quantum computing comes
from the continuity
uh is there a limit so for example like
if it's broken up into a thousand
different
instead of an infinite amount of
superposition it's a thousand
discrete superpositions yeah that would
certainly
that would be a problem no that would
definitely be a problem um i was
thinking of like if you
uh discretized it as in like you don't
allow it to be real numbers but you
allow it to be
any um like a rational number um i think
if you
start putting into finite numbers yeah
that would be a problem
have you heard of wolfram's principle of
computational equivalence
um i'm not sure if i have okay so it's
like an extension of the church
thesis church turing thesis except he
says that
all physical phenomena are have have a
computational basis
okay do you agree with that and yeah
that sounds
that sounds 100 like like i mean i'm
very biased as a person who
studied quantum computing because like
the reason why
quantum computing is interesting to me
is because i fundamentally accept that
um that everything in the universe is a
computation in the sense that a
computation is like
you have some objects and they follow
some rules and that just determines what
they're doing at the next time step
and so that like to me is exactly what
physics is and so i've like yeah no
no like yeah to me that's
like definitely true okay great
okay now you had some some choice words
to say about the bohmian pilot wave
theory okay why do you not particularly
like it
oh i i do particularly like it um so
i i actually think that um
like i don't think i believe it um but i
think that is a really
really important theory to have in mind
because a lot of the things that we want
to say about
quantum mechanics or we think is like
obviously true about quantum mechanics
um binomial mechanic bohmian mechanics
provides an
excellent counter example for so it's
something to like always be keeping in
mind
um when you're talking about the
foundations of quantum mechanics
and yeah like i think it's an ingenious
theory i think that
it doesn't extend well to relativity uh
which is why i don't think it's true
but for just straight up quantum
mechanics itself
it is like yeah just such a beautiful
counter example to a lot of things
people say
okay i heard you say that on the
eigenvalues podcast that it doesn't
extend to
well you said that it's
non-renormalizable but i wasn't able
to find that result did you can you
there's a paper on that
i'm assuming there are some papers on
this but it's not
it's not that it isn't possible but that
um
that it seems so it is probably possible
to reproduce the
um like the the phenomena of
of special relativity but not to
reproduce the sort of like
underlying um beauty of special
relativity which is like
relativity that um like you know frames
of reference don't matter and that sort
of thing
there's a paper a fairly recent paper
2019 this guy named pinto pintonetto
and strove i don't know if you heard of
them no
okay well they showed that with a
bohmian interpretation
you can have you can have quantum
gravity
and in a way that doesn't have the
the parts of heterotic string theory and
supersymmetric string theory and
and loop quantum that they have some
pastiferous parts to them when it comes
to
quantizing gravity so what they used is
an approach of canonical quantum gravity
and apparently
when you use a bomium interpretation it
helps
form some even predictive aspects of
quantum cosmology
so that's why i was wondering why is it
non-renormalizable when
like i couldn't find that result and i i
heard you say that on the eigenbros
podcast and i was like where's and then
they're like yeah it is non-normalizable
i'm like what yeah
and i searched for this but i could yeah
okay so there i
don't know if i said non-normalizable
but
um definitely like the thing that i was
thinking of
was um like that that it is frame
dependent
um so it has like a privileged frame of
reference i think
which is quite like not in the spirit of
relativity yeah yeah yeah even if it can
reproduce the results and and like
to be fair like if it can reproduce the
results very well
or even like have good um predictions
about like
you know where where all these things
are gonna go then then that is very
exciting and
we like you know maybe should give up on
like the beauty of relativity a little
bit
if it's gonna be useful um so i'm not
like i don't have a strong position on
that
but my my like sort of gut feeling was
like
having not read this paper that you're
mentioning um
that like if it had to have like a
sort of privileged frame of reference
that it would probably make the
the math of it like kind of too hard to
like be really workable
um and so that was why i wasn't
a fan of it like i didn't feel like it
could extend well
do you have an opinion that the laws of
physics like let's say the theory of
everything is ultimately beautiful
symmetric and so on
or do you or you're like yeah i mean i'm
not physicist be it as it comes
yeah no i like i mean i i
maybe should be one of those people
who's like oh you know whatever it is
that's that's the truth
um but like of course like my training
is in physics and
we get this like idea sort of
hammered into us the whole way along
that that
things that are true are beautiful um
and it just so happens to have been the
case
for so long and even in mathematics um i
feel like this is true that the things
that are true
are beautiful because um like
the beauty of it is like us recognizing
how
like elegant and simple the solution is
um
and it feels it would just be
weird for all this like complexity in
the universe to exist without some like
very beautiful elegant rules to have
produced them
but of course it's like very possible
and i i you know i don't hold on to it
too strongly
we're gonna wrap up but i have some
specific questions for
some of the people who are let's say in
their second year of physics so they're
just taking quantum mechanics
and then some audience questions too
okay so miles ignotus says i'd like to
know her thoughts on cubism
yeah okay so this is like a really great
question and it is
something that i've been wanting to like
learn more about to actually make a
video about and just just generally know
more about for myself
um but i don't know enough but my sort
of gut
reaction to it is like i just feel
uncomfortable with um physical theories
that put that really privileged the
observer and
privileged the observer's knowledge
about the universe and
kind of almost suggests the universe
doesn't exist without us
processing the knowledge and like again
this is very much my bias like coming
from physics where
it's all about like sort of
objectiveness and like humans being
removed from the
like humans kind of stumbling onto the
universe and like trying to understand
it as it is rather than creating the
universe in
our own minds um so this is my gut
reaction against cubism
but i think that there's like a lot of
um
interesting mathematics that has been
derived by cubism
that like is definitely worth um looking
into and something that i really want to
do
just us perths i don't know if i'm
pronouncing that correctly says how can
a person who is self-studying deal with
gaps in knowledge
when i get stuck on a new concept i'm
often unsure what exactly it is that's
preventing me from understanding it
i.e i don't know what i'm missing and
what i need to study in order to get it
this is such yeah this is really tough
like i've
had the same problem many times when
studying myself
um i think uh
you yeah like in in some ways
being a beginner and getting stuck in
these ways is like
a real privilege and i know this sounds
really
weird to say but um
like being a beginner and uh recognizing
what you don't know
is a state that you can like almost not
get back into in fact i think that
one of the reasons i like teaching
beginners is because then i have to put
myself in that mindset
um and like yeah so being able to
recognize what you don't know is like
really really valuable and as you go on
you'll basically like plaster over the
bits that you don't actually understand
so definitely like try and recognize
what you don't understand and
when you get to that situation um like
if you can
like look for sort of you know
introductory textbooks or some
some material like that and understand
it from that that's great
but if it doesn't solve your problem
like keep that as a question mark
like you know keep it as like okay i
still don't understand this bit
i'm gonna keep this as a question i
don't know the answer i'll move on
like i'll read some other things either
like you know tangentially or i'll just
go on in
whatever i'm reading but um as i
read like if something answers that
questions for me i'll come back
i imagine that as you're doing your phd
you don't have the time to
go through the books and solve all the
problems and i know that solving the
problems
helps your understanding greatly but
because you have to
cover such a vast amount of research so
quickly that means that
you have to have a superficial
understanding of so much but then you
have to know what is it okay for me to
have a superficial understanding of
so that i can pretty much with a hop
skip and a jump go to the go to where i
need to be
so how do you get how do you balance
that that tightrope of
of having tenuous knowledge and
and strengthen deep knowledge okay yeah
so
um during my phd
the thing i was just saying about the
benefit of being
a beginner i tried to really take that
to heart
um so when there was a topic i didn't
know
i mostly avoided it only like kind of
knowing
it superficially from talks that i would
go to
just enough to kind of like understand
what the vague like what the problem was
in that in that area and like what they
were trying to solve
but i would like purposely not really
jump into it and then
i would like take various topics like
new topics that i didn't know
so so one of them was like um conomera
correction
like i'd heard about it in a lot of
talks and i knew what the problem was
um but i'd never dived into it so then i
took some time
to specifically go and read all the
introductory material on that
and like really dive into it because i
feel like
there isn't that much benefit of having
like a
more than superficial knowledge of of
certain topics of physics uh whereas
there's a huge amount of benefit to
being an absolute beginner
and like really really diving into a
topic
um because like yeah i remember one one
of the examples
that comes to mind is like uh i try to
learn about
um fermions and bosons in the context of
computing
um because there was like a bunch of
really interesting results about like
boson sampling and um fermionic linear
optics
and i wanted to like like i i knew about
them but i wanted to go back to the
basics like i want to understand what is
a feminine what is that boson
uh what have they got to do with quantum
computing and
so like i really really really went back
to like
the absolute basics spent ages on it and
i remember giving this presentation to
my group and a few other people who are
there who were
basically experts in in the topic of
like how this relates to computing
and i was talking about something like
super basic but even so
like i felt like there was some parts
where i knew
stuff better and like i'd been able to
make some connections that i think
weren't as clear
if you um uh like you know
like again not not as the like the
experts obviously anymore but the people
who were like
fairly well versed in it i feel like
there was some points in which i
like knew more than them just from like
really diving into like but what does
this mean and where do i have
uncertainty and just like keep going
until you really get some get to the
bottom of it yeah and when you're doing
this process of
of diving in and finding out where your
holes are
are you taking a blank sheet of paper
and writing out almost like the feynman
method
i'm sure you've heard where you teach
yourself or you pretend there's a third
person
100 yeah so what i do is i collect like
so in this case it was papers i
collected a whole bunch of papers but
you know it could be books
um i never read through a book uh
like front to back um like i never sort
of
want to get something from just one
source instead i'll uh
read one source kind of get like
something from it
um like maybe i'll read the introduction
and then i'll kind of write down what i
think i know and then i'll go into
another source and see if that kind of
like gels well
um they might be using different
location they might be looking at it
from slightly
different perspective sorry your
your fans your photographer fans i know
um
uh yeah okay so yeah i'll never read
i'll never read anything um front back
instead i'll
read a lot of different things with
different perspectives
and as i go i'll like be keeping a um
like a whole lot of notes where i'm
basically trying to explain it to myself
like i'll be like a fermion is
and then i'll write one definition and
then in the other source it'll have an
entirely different but equivalent
definition
and i'll like like i'll read that they
don't reference each other they don't
talk about how they're related to each
other so
then i have to like you know in my
writing like figure out how is this
thing that they said
the same as what they said just in a
different language and so
like the translation process is really
interesting and like i'll learn a lot
from that
and then like yeah just just like um
kind of like keeping many sources uh
in mind as i'm writing these notes that
are like how would i explain this to
someone else is very useful do you find
that
books are most helpful or do you watch
lectures online
i almost never watch lectures online um
i think it's mostly an attention thing i
actually kind of find it hard to watch
video
um and a lot easier to read uh but
i what i feel what i find lectures
better for than
um than textbooks is to get a
opinion from the person like opinions
during talks are so
useful you get the sort of sense of like
what this person
thinks is the interesting parts of this
field like
what are the real mysteries according to
this person whereas i feel like books
are you know a lot
a lot more long-winded in their
introduction so it's harder to get that
feel of like the person's opinion um but
then i think books are better for like
diving in
i'm gonna just read this one verbatim so
how is it specifically that
the mathematical notion of an observable
as an operator corresponds to a physical
device
so what you're doing is you're
manipulating symbols in the abstract and
it's not
clear how it corresponds to what's going
on experimentally
now that's something that when you're in
second third even even for like
you don't get unless you take
experimental physics you don't get an
understanding of so what the heck
doesn't mean that the operator isn't
position operator's x and or the
derivative if it's momentum and so on
how does that correspond to what's going
on when you observe in the lab
yeah yeah these are great questions um
no this is a great question
and it confused me for a long time um
and
i only kind of realized much later that
that there is no good science to the way
that we make the operators in fact
there's a lot of art to it
um what we usually do is we so like
again to make an operator
for a um measurement you've got to
consider
what uh what are you like physically
doing
so you know in the stone girl like
experiment um we're
actually physically applying a magnetic
field ultimately that's what we're doing
um and whatever measurement you're doing
you're ultimately physically doing
something
and you've got to write down like what
are the
so the hamiltonian which is essentially
like what are the forces
that you're you're you're um uh creating
in this measurement device and then you
write that down classically
and then you just do this sort of like
cheap trick
of uh of quantization where you take and
like the
the quant like so the classical version
of um a certain
object like the magnetic field and then
you make it a quantum operator and then
you're like okay
just do that and there we go that's my
quantum operator for this this
measurement whatever i'm doing so it's
not that satisfying
what's the operator for determining the
charge of an electron or its mass
operators correspond to observables
yeah so this one is not an observable um
the reason is because you couldn't
observe a electron to
be in a different um
have a different mass or charge on the
other hand now that i say that
um you could come up with a uh
operator that measures the charge of a
particle just a random particle
um i have no clue
what that operator would look like i
think you'd have to ask someone who
actually does experiments how do
operators look in terms of experiments
now can one design an experiment and
work backward to find the operator
yeah that's what you do you've got to
look at the experiment look at what
forces you're applying and then
write those out do quantization that
will get you that braid up pretty much
three more questions ryan conlin says
when you study how much time do you
spend thinking about your own particular
background knowledge and skills that is
relating it to previous knowledge
versus how much time do you spend do you
spend thinking about it
without relating oh super interesting
question
actually i find it's really really
useful to relate it to your background
knowledge
at least for me during the phd um i
think maybe that's partly a quirk of the
phd where
like you you're studying but you also
want to be able to add something new to
the knowledge
um like the knowledge base and so going
from the angle of like
how can i relate this to those the
particular quirky things that i know
um is like a good way to sort of start
making new things
um but just generally i think it's like
really a good strategy
when you're studying to um you know
you've learned some new concept
let's say you've just learned what a
group is and
in abstract algebra and uh if you can
find like some examples that are related
to things you've learned so for example
if you related that to the symmetries in
in relativity because you've just
learned about relativity that will make
it
way more concrete and way easier for you
to understand
so i think that is actually a really
important thing that's like super
neglected by students so
yeah like great question at the same
time i can see how sometimes
trying to relate it back can be
counterproductive for example in
quantum mechanics and sages forget what
you know that's gonna hold you back
so at what point do you abandon versus
relate
um i think that's uh the thing on
quantum mechanics
i think that's not true like uh
if you're learning quantum mechanics
mathematically
like you're trying to understand the
math it's extremely important
to relate what you are seeing there to
what you know about classical mechanics
um like we were just talking about
how do you find operators uh well you
got to know hamiltonian mechanics quite
well
that and that's from classical um the
classical side so
okay for for your intuitions yes you
have to let go of a lot you don't know
but for uh like the the sort of
machinery often things are building on
each other michael mcguffin says
what has she been reading recently and
then also part two is like if her
financial incomes were met
say she's given 10 million dollars what
would you spend your time doing
uh books and then time okay cool um
thank you for those questions uh
so um what am i reading i'm reading a
few things um
i recently finished a book by uh
the um the
director of pixar um creativity inc and
uh it was about how to create like a
creative product
in um in a corporation which like
often kind of stifle creativity uh so
how do you keep that alive
that was super interesting um on a sort
of similar vein
uh a friend of mine recommended um the
idea factory
and that was about bill labs so bell
labs was like quite famous for
having invented a whole bunch of like
really ahead of their times um
devices and it was a similar deal to
pixar in a way where like they managed
to
come up with like a corporate
environment because it was a corporation
it wasn't a university or anything
a corporate environment that somehow
could still stimulate um creativity
and in this case in science um so yeah i
think that's like a really interesting
topic to me like something that i'm
really interested in about like it's
just
innovation in general but how do you um
how do you foster
it uh and then like i guess if someone
was to give me
uh 10 million dollars um there
are a bunch of product projects that i'm
um
like you know interested in um like i'm
very keen on like what
on understanding what the future of
education is going to be
um i think that there needs to be like
even more research i mean there's like
lots of great research at the moment but
even more research and even more focus
put into like how can we
really change the way that humans learn
um so that they are really like
achieving their maximum
human potential i think that schools are
really wonderful
um and i'm not one of those people who
is like advocating for like just ripping
it all down
um but i think that they're inefficient
in certain ways like they just have to
be because of how they were sort of
made and because of all the various
pressures that are on schools
um so i would love to understand like if
we were going to make it from scratch
um what what would we keep but what
would we change
um have you heard of forgetting this
guy's name starts with
peter of the evolutionary institute
peter peter gray that's right right
okay so anyway have you heard of peter
gray's unschooling
i have but i'm blanking can you
essentially so it's not like tear down
the schools but what i'm saying is that
the
that kid is taking an evolutionary
psychological approach to
learning that kids learn best in mixed
age groups
and one of the reasons is that there's
no bullying because you're eight you're
not going to compete with a 16 year old
and you're
not vice versa and then the 16 year old
is not going to compete with a 24 year
old
and he takes this from observing tribes
that don't have schools
and the kids just learn automatically
because play is so important and when
they're playing they just
they happen to learn and it's
spontaneous and you allow the kid to
follow their own interests and you
encourage it yeah instead of imposing
one
yeah so i think this this whole movement
um of inquiry-based learning is
very very interesting but also um i
think we have to be a little careful
with it
uh i i'm i'm definitely
for um kids being able to like figure
out what they like
themselves and just like go down that
rabbit hole like that's you know a big
part of like
my education was that um but
i think on the other hand like letting
kids have completely free reign
um i mean there has been some research
about this like
it just doesn't work as well if you have
like no
sort of um either discipline or uh
like guidance about where to go because
you know you're not going to expect a
child playing on their own to rediscover
mutants laws
like that's just not possible um but on
the other hand if you had like a
a supervising figure who was there to
like encourage
uh the you know the interests as they as
they develop
and sees that you know this person's
interested in how things work and it's
like oh have you read
these interesting books like that could
potentially work i think that
um to make that work uh we need to put
like a lot
more thought into just how like we can
guide that experience without
um you know fully determining what the
kid is going to do
ourselves beer's attitude says it would
be cool to know her opinion on donald
hoffman's work
what is the most fundamental level in
her opinion i don't know what that
last sentence means what does she make
of consciousness so i don't know if
you've heard of donald hoffman and his
theories on consciousness but this
person would like to know
yeah okay oh that's in because that's
disappointing because the person's like
oh thank you dude
sorry um wait who is this donald hoffman
is a
is a cognitive scientist
he's a cognitive scientist who says that
what we can do
is model conscious agents with something
like a
markov kernel where you just have let's
say the set of experiences
you don't even give them names like love
or what you just give them whatever you
like and then give them some structure
like
well you can read his papers and then he
says that what you can do from there is
develop the laws of
quantum mechanics now i'm skeptical of
that and i read his research but it's
something like
it's so general you've heard of these
claims like yeah i can derive quantum
mechanics but i derived it from
something so general that it
well i'd be surprised if you couldn't
derive quantum mechanics from that
fair enough but either way donald
hoffman is a bright bright yeah
a bright bright individual uh yeah sorry
i couldn't answer that question
that's right and i also realized that i
have a question on quantum the quantum
parallel thesis
i wanted to know i imagine that you
think it's true given that you
adopt the many worlds interpretation but
i was wondering what are some ways that
the quantum parallel thesis could be
true without
the many world's interpretation um what
do you mean by the quantum parallel
thesis quantum parallel
thesis is that the
it's something like that the computation
is being performed
simultaneously on the superpositions
okay have you heard of the quantum
parallel these uh yeah like deutsches
um yes yeah that's correct that's
correct that's correct yeah um
yeah uh i think what i don't
understand about that idea um
and what makes me skeptical of it is
that
it's not clear how computation from
distinct branches
of the superposition can be
be transferred like how that information
can be transferred
um so like let's say you do uh like
you you want to do a huge number of
computations so you split into many
different worlds
and then you um do one of the
computations in each one of these words
then you have the result in each of
these worlds so let's say you're looking
for a one
and world number three has found a one
and it needs to communicate now to all
the rest of them
um it's
like the way that that communication is
done inside of quantum computing
um it
it depends on those superpositions not
being
um distinct worlds in the sort of many
world sense
so you know in the many world sense um a
super like any superposition is not a
different world it only becomes like a
different world once
it interacts with other things and
therefore can't interact with itself
anymore like so if you have two if you
have a
if you have a superposition of two
things um those sort of worlds can kind
of like
split in a sense and they become
distinct from each other but if they
don't interact with anything else
they can kind of recon recommend so one
way that this could happen is like if
you have a spin particle
um you start it in spin up and then
you um change the magnetic field so it
becomes spin up spin down
and then you change the magnetic field
back and so it spin up again
um like in a way you've deleted the
superposition but this is like
this is totally fine and this is what
happens in quantum computing but
in many worlds you wouldn't say that
that was like two worlds and they
recombined
for many worlds the worlds can't
recombine for them to be like worlds
so yeah anyway basically all right
i i have a quote here about the many
worlds interpretation this is hardly the
most economical view
the most economical of viewpoints but my
own personal objections don't spring
from its lack of economy and
in particular i don't see why a
conscious being need be
aware of only one of the alternatives in
a linear superposition
what is it about consciousness that
demands that one cannot be aware
of the tantalizing linear combination of
being both dead and alive
it seems to me that a theory of
consciousness will be needed before
the many worlds viewed can be squared
with what one actually observes
so what do you think about this yeah i
think that that is a
um a a an understandable objection but i
think
like an objection that is um met by the
mathematics
um so what i mean is okay let's say you
have a
um object that's in a superposition in
many worlds
uh like so it's in two different worlds
um
it can only experience like so let's say
it's not a conscious thing
it's just a let's say an atom um it can
only experience
all of the other objects in its world in
that in the state
that they are in that world so like in
this state like so let's say in this
world
all of the objects are in state zero and
in that world they're all in state one
if you take one of the atoms inside of
here and you get it to measure one of
its partners
it will say that its partner is zero or
here
if you got it to measure its partner it
would say it's one it can only
experience that world
like with all of the things that are in
that world
as they are like you know um in that
state and so
let's say now i'm a conscious being and
i'm inside of
like both of these branches um i've just
done a measurement
of my um of my atom and
uh my atom is now like in state zero
according to in this branch
and in state one according to that
branch if i was to if i was
able to experience both then i should be
able to see the
atom being in state zero and in state
one
but because of how many words works how
the mathematics works out
there is no measurement that i can do
inside of this world that would show me
the result one
it would only say zero and in that world
i would only say one
and so there's no like i don't
experience the other world to me just
doesn't exist there's no evidence of it
anywhere
so of course i don't consciously
experience it
oh so now that there's no evidence of it
anywhere what is the reason for you
believing in it oh so there's evidence
there's all the evidence that i
could possibly want that i'm in the the
world where everything is in state zero
when i'm sorry i meant i meant why does
mathuna mythana sorry
believe in the many world's
interpretation if
to me it seems like a religious choice
because there's not
evidence for it unless you just say well
the math says exactly
so no um it's it's uh back to that
question of like
do i want a um theory of the universe to
be beautiful or not
um i my my bias is very much towards
beauty
um and i think that many worlds is a
much more beautiful theorem
uh theory rather and that's because it
has less assumptions
so in a statement there oh many worlds
is less economical
in one sense yes if you're like counting
worlds but i think that's not the
sort of important sense of like um you
know how
economical a theory is how economical it
is is like
how many sort of distinct ad hoc rules
does it have
and many worlds deletes the ad hoc rule
that quantum mechanics has and therefore
i think it is a more economical more
beautiful theory that's why i believe it
it's not because of the evidence because
thank you so much
thank you so much so what's next for you
um uh after this next youtube video
um yeah uh well so the thing i've been
thinking
the most about is how to improve online
education
i think that that's like a really uh
like interesting and new medium um like
people on youtube have done
really wonderful things but i think that
like we can push it even further
um so yeah that's the direction i hope
to to like
put myself um and like it's sad that i'm
not doing physics research like i
i miss it but i feel like this is higher
impact like i feel like
the world needs this more than you know
the small bit of physics that i
could have contributed wait so are you
more driven by that
altruistic part of you or the passion
part of you that just wants to do
research
yeah um i think that um
yeah like i really am passionate about
physics research and so it was like a
super hard decision
but because um education
will impact like way more people and
also because it is still a very
interesting thing to research
um ultimately like both of those things
combined made it a pretty good choice
thank you so much for spending so much
time with with me
and putting up with my sleepy questions
oh good i'm sorry for that i'm catching
oh no no no no no it's
it's all right it's sorry i i just for
the for weeks and weeks
like weeks i haven't been getting enough
sleep and so it just
compiles and compiles yeah yeah
and then i've been studying some quantum
computing to prep for this
oh no oh thanks so much well
i'm just going to ask this yeah yeah no
problem no problem
there's so many other technic somewhat
technical questions i had like about zx
calculus
and i was wondering about the
relationship between graph states and
the spider diagrams are the
oh my gosh their way of are they this i
know the graph states
see the way that i i understand graph
states are like
in particle physics there's definement
diagrams and then there's rules to
translate those to
equations looks like graph states have a
simple rule
and then i was wondering is there a way
to go from graph states to zx
spiders yeah well anyway
i'm curious is there yeah um i don't
actually know
like they have different uses i'm sure
but yeah as far as i know from
my depthless understanding of quantum
computing they're just representations
of the circuits
so i don't so i don't see why one is
more advantageous than the other or why
they can't be easily translated to one
another
yeah that's a good question um yeah
that is a really good question and i i
genuinely don't know the answer to that
yeah
okay okay well anyway whatever
anyway well no thank you so much for
this interview thank you
thank you
you